Paul good to see you again my man
congrats on this thanks Carlos
so I gotta ask you what was the like the
day that you knew you were gonna go
toe-to-toe with John Majors I mean we
know he knows his way around a fight
scene he can really throw a punch what
was that they like
well the actual time we were when we
were fighting was more than a day
it was more like a about a two weeks
and it was a rough two weeks it was it
was amazing
um but it was hard hard to film and hard
to choreograph and it was exhausting but
um but it was cool I mean he's you know
he we shot this and then he was going
off to do Creed so
um he was definitely in fight mode
he's an amazing actor and I would buy
him as the world heavyweight champ you
know I think it he um he he he could
pull it off
well you guys you guys really pulled off
is amazing
um I I love the idea of Scott meeting
all his multiversalves uh but I'm
wondering you know being a huge fan of
your work and all the different
characters that you've got what would
Brian fantana have done
um the moment he started meeting all of
his
multiversalves if it was Brian fantana
from Anchorman in there if it was Brian
fantana regardless of whatever Universe
he was in and he realized that he could
shrink down
he would probably shrink down and uh use
those abilities for nefarious reasons
and he would probably go to see uh
people like you know undressing uh to be
invisible you know he would and uh I'm
sure he would only ever use it for
really like creepy reasons and uh
and there would be nothing heroic about
him at all
um I gotta ask you as well you know I'm
I'm getting an opportunity to play uh
mini golf against Catherine Newton this
week and to be perfectly honest with you
I know she is an amazing golfer and I'm
actually quite intimidated by the idea
of it do you have any advice for me like
I don't know how how good you are on a
Mini Putt chorus but anything you could
tell me about going head-to-head against
Catherine this week well
um yeah you're probably gonna lose but I
don't know about like mini golf is a
different thing if you were playing
regular golf I would say well you'll
definitely lose I don't play golf
um mini golf is fun but like I don't you
know if you're a pro you still got to
deal with that windmill you still got to
deal with the thing that goes upside
down in a big loop or a weird bounce but
um you know it's it's it's mini golf it
it I think you'll you'll you'll be okay
she's a she's a blast she'll uh she'll
it's great you're gonna love spending
time with her I know I did but um
you know and and then if all else fails
try and um I guess I'll go back to
Caddyshack go for the hamstring she puts
the weight on the hamstring cut and then
and then her and then her game is gonna
be
I mean it depends do you want to have a
friendly interview or do you want it to
get seriously competitive and you'll go
to whatever means necessary to hamper
her game
I both both choices are valid
yes true fair fair I appreciate the
advice Paul thanks so much for your time
man good luck good luck by the way turn
my voice crack good luck you have no
faith in me that's why I want to tell
you I want to tell you seriously good
luck with your golf game against
Catherine and I hope you like the movie
that's me on the inside thanks buddy
thanks man